all right from fashion to the swag
topgolf host this year's grammy gift
lounge and we got a sneak peek at what
all the stars are getting our gifting
guru lash ferry takes us on a
[Music]
tour we are doing our 23rd official
grammy gift lounge we started this
concept so many years ago and it's still
as popular today as it was back then and
it's really a perk for the show they get
a pre-assembled gift bag which is
actually two pieces of luggage filled
with amazing stuff that they get to
wheel away and then we have this
interactive component and we are being
hosted by topgolf las vegas here on the
mgm property there are two new topgolf
locations in the los angeles area and
the stars are getting a vip package to
experience that we have peta here who's
helping the stars run towards a kinder
planet with newton running shoes that
are absolutely and 100 cruelty free
gross city japan they've been with us
for so many years previously we've had
melissa etheridge cindy lauper a little
nasdaq sandra day pick out amazing
jewelry we've got skinny spoof socks and
they're getting these awesome socks this
is africa's number one premium sock
brand and they are here with us well
i've been giving rosebox nyc flower
arrangements for years what's so
incredible they're real roses that have
been specially treated to last up to a
year maintenance free and they put them
in these adorable acrylic jewelry boxes
and then we also have a whole
interactive augmented reality experience
for them from you where they're creating
a 3d custom performing avatar of robert
johnson the blues legend i mean we've
covered all of our bases there's no
favorite moment for me when a first-time
performer on the show gets to come
through and experience all of this